good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today is scp
4495
object class
ketter
threat level
yellow
following the regular implementation of
procedures 610 sinclair
scp-4495 has achieved sufficient
ecto-entropic stability and is no longer
considered at risk of instigating an nk
class scenario legacy containment
procedures are kept on record in the
event that 610 sinclair is no longer
viable
special containment procedures
relevant personnel are to execute
procedures 610 sinclair on a daily basis
and maintenance personnel are to inspect
scp-4495's containment chamber on a
bi-weekly basis
scp-4495 is contained inside of a
three-tiered cell each tier separated by
a graded floor
scp-4495 resides on the top tier
strapped into an alcove in the southern
wall
scp-4495 stomach is positioned at an
acute angle with respect to the floor
allowing
scp-4495-1 to immediately fall through
the grating upon generation to prevent
the buildup of stuck instances of
scp-4495-1
the grading is to be sprayed hourly by a
series of built-in pressure washers the
top tier is to remain refrigerated in
the interests of reducing miasma
the middle tier contains a combination
grinder and incinerator instances of
scp-4495-1 are forced into the machine
through a funnel emerging from the
bottom as a temporarily inert paste this
process takes under 10 minutes
the bottom tier contains implements
required form procedures 610 sinclair
should procedure 610 sinclair become
non-viable
scp-4495-1 paste is to be pressed as
thinly as possible vacuum sealed and
stored in 56's provisional storage wing
relevant personnel are to read document
4495 610 at the nearest opportunity
description
scp-4495 is the partially decomposed
corpse of an unidentified cryptid
superficially it resembles a bipedal pig
clad and regalware reclaiming upon a
throne however closer examination
reveals that the throne figure and
ryman's all constitute a single immobile
organism comprised of keratin bone and
skin
scp-4495's ventral torso has ruptured
periodic contractions along its
abdominal cavity continuously forces
instances of scp-4495-1
outward instances of scp-449251
superficially resemble porcine
intestines
scp-4495
are animate and behave in a manner
roughly analogous to pythons with the
exception of extreme aggression in the
presence of animal life
while instances of
scp-4495-1 can be damaged normally they
will reform if given enough time
exposure to high temperatures delays
this process but is not halted entirely
scp-4495-1 can only be permanently
destroyed through application of
procedures 610 sinclair
document 4495 610 analysis of scp-4495-1
and details of procedures 610 sinclair
analysis of scp-449
the following is a full-scale analysis
of scp-4495-1
authorized on 2608 2008 by director
agatha drummond and primarily conducted
by doctors rivka yarkoni and daniel gums
this study was taken under the following
assumptions
number one that scp-4495
was either related to or intended to
resemble a member of the suidi family of
animals
number two that
scp-4495 could be considered alive dead
or inanimate but theories which claimed
inanimacy must remain exclusive from
ones suggesting a biological origin
number three that if
scp-4495 could only be considered alive
or dead
scp-4495-1 was related to or intended to
resemble animal intestines
number four that scp-4495
ran the risk of causing an nk-class
grey-goose scenario if a method of
permanently destroying scp-4495-1
was not developed
as stated in
scp-4495's description
scp-4495-1 resemble porcine intestines
however instances of scp-4495-1
are variable in shape and size to the
extent that assuming
scp-4495-1 functions as a theoretical
living instance of
scp-4495's intestines
scp-4495 as a species would either have
possessed a theoretically infinite
number of vestigial digestive systems or
a radically variable diet between
individuals
scp-4495-1 was initially subjected to
several rounds of chemical testing
initial reports concluded that
scp-4495-1
was chemically inert however as such a
conclusion would necessitate the usage
of anomalous disposal methods the pepper
protocol was invoked and chemical
testing was to be continued for a period
of one week
on o209 2008 junior researcher malcolm
johnson violated quarantine protocols
when he vomited on his respective batch
of scp-4495-1
novel chemical reactions were
immediately observed
details of procedures 610 sinclair
1.
scp-4495
paste is cleansed of grime through a
food-safe cleaning mechanism
number 2 the resulting paste is then
reheated over a period of an hour at 400
degrees celsius
number three paste is separated into a
series of measured portions depending on
the culinary attitudes of the foundation
number four portions are to be fitted
with fake casing
number five portions are to be served to
foundation personnel on standard diet
plans in lieu of pork
six unsold portions are to be fed to
d-class personnel as part of ura
2677's containment protocols
number seven uneaten portions of
scp-4495-1 are to be filtered out of
site-56's waste disposal system
thoroughly cleansed and retreated with
procedures 610 sinclair
extensive experimentation shows that
scp-4495-1 is culinarily similar to
comet pork with superior nutritional
benefits and lower levels of cholesterol
and saturated fats this in addition to
its longevity
scp-4495-1 treated with procedure 610
sinclair does not decay and will remain
inanimate for approximately two weeks
without additional heat treatment
most importantly in addition to
providing a better ratio of caloric
content consumption of
scp-4495-1 produces virtually no waste
matter a significant portion of
scp-4495-1
is essentially annihilated upon
digestion
mass implementation of procedure 610
sinclair is projected to save a
significant amount of money on culinary
expenses disinformation efforts are
underway in the form of increased
sanitary regulations
well i think i can speak for all of us
here at the foundation that that was
absolutely disgusting
but that concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
anvil
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
givios the hollow
zazapan
jordan c wilde
lamke
dr briggs
tailored printers
perpetually confused meet mac pilot
cignar
kaii lacks empathy
alitreon
your local foundation agent
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate the clown
lost boy
a real american hebrew
scio dio demnatus
the morrigan and
james saba
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vulgan
thank you
[Music]
you